So we have our object diagram started,
and
right now these objects
are just floating around.
We haven't really talked about
how they might be interconnected.
So let's add some connections, or if
we're going to use the more formal term,
we'll say let's add some relationships.
Relationships that we're going to add
are going to be ones that we've borrowed
from UML.
Those are the contains relationship, and
the kind of, or kind of relationship.
And these are also known by other names,
for
instance contains might
be known as part of,
kind of might also be known as a type
of, and there's other variations too.
So what do these mean?
Let's start with
the contains relationship.
Like it sounds, a contains relationship
is representative of when an object
contains another object.
If we think about the world object, it
contains a robot, it contains an alien.
There's a background.
It also has a dialogue bubble and
the badge here,
but we're going to leave those out for
now.
So in our diagram, let's create some
relationships between the world and
the robot, the alien,
and the background.
So I'm going to go ahead and
move some things around just
to make some extra space.
And to represent
the contains relationship,
we'll draw arrows from the world object
to the objects that it contains, and
label them as contains relationships.
Pay close attention to
the direction of the arrows.
For these relationships, it's
pointing from the world to the robot,
to the alien, and to the background.
And the reason that it points in
this direction is it allows us to
read the relationship by
just following the arrow.
Now we could also say
that the app contains
each of the objects in this diagram,
but if I'm going to add an arrow for
every single object in our diagram,
it could get a little hard to follow.
To keep our diagram simple we just
want to add the contains relationships
from the app to the most
high level objects.
By high level, I mean objects that are
bigger in the sense that they have more
complexity about them.
For instance, the world object is at
a higher level than the alien object
in a sense that it probably has more
functionality contained within it.
Another way to think about it is that
the world probably plays a bigger role
as part of the app than the alien does.
In general you want to keep this going
from the most high level object,
like in this case the Alien Adventure,
to the lower level objects.
So, for instance,
an Alien Adventure contains a world,
a world contains a robot,
robot can contain a badge, and
we can add a relationship for
that later.
Now, the distinctions that
we're making here and
these relationships that we're adding,
again they're completely up to you.
Where I'm using a contains relationship
between the world and the alien,
you might use something else, or might
not even have a relationship at all or
where I'm labeling this as a contains
relationship I might not even have that.
I might even remove alien adventure
because the world is kind of the most
[INAUDIBLE] object.
By the title here we know that we're
talking about the alien adventure app.
But again,
it's just personal preference.
You can do whatever you want to.
So moving on,
let's talk about the other relationship.
The kind of relationship.
This is one of my favorites.
It used to describe objects
that have similarities and
it also involves a little
bit of abstract thinking.
For instance, let's think
about the alien and the robot.
They’re actually pretty similar.
The robot and the alien can animate.
We saw that the robot could move
across the screen and the alien's
animating right now and they’re
both able to speak to each other,
so in a sense they’re a little
bit like actors in a play.
Now this is the abstract part.
The aliens and
the robot are like actors in a play.
Then why not add an object to our
diagram that represents an actor.
I mean that sounds pretty good to me.
An actor is an object
that can be animated and
participates in discussions.
And just like we said, both the alien
and the robot are kinds of actors.
And that's how we'll add
this kind of relationship.
We'll start by adding
an actor to the diagram.
And then we'll add relationships
from the alien to the actor.
Because an alien is a kind of actor and
from the robot to the actor because
the robot is a kind of actor.
And I hope you've noticed that for
these kind of relationships,
the direction of the arrows again.
We're going from the alien to the actor,
so it reads very naturally and
alien is a kind of actor.
And we can take this one step further.
We can simplify our diagram and
say that the world contains actors,
and then get rid of the arrows that we
have from the world to the robot, and
from the world to the alien.
So I'll give you just
a second to let that soak in.
The world contains actors, and
the actors can be robots or aliens.
And the world also
contains a background, or
that's what we have so far.